pasamos a temas de economía quien tras
24 y estamos para eso con daniel
hablando que nos va a contar lo más
importante de esta jornada ni en la
bienvenida y vamos a eeuu que no
ampliarán las ayudas adicionales a los
desempleados hola qué tal y liana pues
el próximo 6 de septiembre expira el
refuerzo de 300 dólares semanales en el
subsidio de desempleo y la expectativa
se ciernen sobre si habrá o no una
extensión pues la respuesta parece que
ya la dio el gobierno del presidente joe
biden la secretaria del tesoro janet
yellen y el de trabajo martin wolf
enviaron una carta al comité de finanzas
del senado en la que recalcaron que el
esfuerzo se planteó como temporal y ya
tienen que finalizar dada la mejoría de
la economía aunque si existirá la
posibilidad de que los gobiernos locales
de los estados más afectados por la
variante delta puedan usar fondos
federales más allá de esa fecha
justamente este jueves se conoció que
las peticiones de subsidios por
desempleo cayeron en la última semana a
348 mil este es un nivel más bajo en lo
que va de la pandemia
bueno y hablamos de uno de los temas del
día daniela porque en méxico se conoció
los resultados de la votación sindical
de la general motors así es liliana pues
el gobierno confirmó que la mayoría de
trabajadores rechazó seguir con el
contrato colectivo que tienen vigente
con la compañía estadounidense se trata
de una consulta clave en el tratado
comercial de mec que entró en vigencia
hace un año entre méxico estados unidos
y canadá nuestro corresponsal en ciudad
de méxico mario carbonero nos contó más
detalles
por mayoría de votos más de 5 mil 800
trabajadores de la planta de general
motors en silao guanajuato decidieron
rechazar el actual contrato colectivo de
trabajo y con ello el sindicato miguel
trujillo afiliado a la confederación de
trabajadores de méxico la
deja de tener la titularidad de este
contrato que queda sin efecto y por ello
deja también de tener la representación
sindical es importante señalar que este
ejercicio es la reposición de una
votación de abril pasado en la que hubo
irregularidades y además quejas ante
eeuu en esta ocasión el ejercicio fue
observado por el instituto nacional
electoral y por la organización
internacional del trabajo y va acorde
con las cláusulas del tratado de libre
comercio el tratado méxico-estados
unidos-canadá teme que como así lo
indica para garantizar la democracia
sindical
los empleados conservarán sus
condiciones laborales y sus derechos
adquiridos y ahora estarán en libertad
de asociarse de ponerse de acuerdo para
la firma de un nuevo contrato colectivo
con una organización gremial que tenga
la representación
por ciento al menos 30 por ciento de los
trabajadores de esta planta armadora de
autos hablamos ahora de perú porque el
gobierno entregará bonos de ayuda a sus
ciudadanos claro que si aprobó entregar
una partida de unos 85 dólares a
poblaciones vulnerables y colectivos
afectados por la crisis económica que ha
causado en la pandemia la ayuda será
individual así que los hogares con dos
adultos podrán recibir unos 170 dólares
y los funcionarios públicos cuyo sueldo
sea superior a
855 dólares mensuales serán excluidos de
este beneficio según explicó el
ejecutivo el bono es similar al
entregado en dos ocasiones por los
anteriores gobierno liliana bueno y
hablamos ahora de francia porque el país
galo recibió su primer desembolso del
fondo de recuperación europeo son
exactamente cinco mil cien millones de
euros que hacen parte del primer
desembolso del fondo de recuperación
comunitaria en total francia va a
recibir 40 mil millones para financiar
su plan de recuperación de aquí a 2026
como parte de los acuerdos de
financiación con misión europea y otros
países como españa italia lituania
grecia bélgica luxemburgo y portugal ya
han recibido financiación de este
mecanismo también y cuéntenos cómo están
los indicadores de la jornada wall
street de cerró mixto en medio del temor
a que la reserva federal retire sus
estímulos este año las acciones europeas
cayeron a su mayor pérdida diaria en un
mes provocada por una caída en los
precios de las materias primas y en
américa latina la bolsa de buenos aires
cerró en terreno negativo por tercer día
consecutivo y rápidamente la cifra al
día hasta en unos 7,1 millones de
vehículos se reducirá la producción de
automóviles en todo el mundo debido a
las clases mundiales de semiconductores
según estima y hs market que es una
reconocida consultora británica gracias
daniela por la información de economía y
ustedes gracias contribuyen con más
entradas 24 punto com
[Música]